[Music]
the way i've always been doing things
just doesn't work now
i want to be free
you're a freak you're fat your hair is
gross you're a baby you smile don't be a
[ __ ] everyone can see you you should be
falling
[Music]
there don't you feel better now
[Music]
i feel weird lately
are you sick
you know the committee in your head that
tells you that you're a terrible person
you're nothing just never really noticed
him before you know what i'm talking
about sure you're a loser
are you okay you're so selfish i just
don't feel like i'm on top of things
loosen up the way i've always been doing
things just doesn't work now
[Music]
you're so beautiful so delicate i feel
sick i've been telling myself to do
certain things hey sugarplum let it go
act a certain way there's nothing better
than watching her get all excited don't
cause a scene or else something bad will
happen to me
how could you be so stupid
maybe you cast yourself in a part you
don't want to play anymore you're a
pretty little girl
i'm scared to do things differently
you're going to fail
[Music]
i'm not listening to that voice
what did you say i'm a sucker for
[Music]
you'll never find your way back to that
kind of freedom i don't want to be
afraid of some terrible outcome i want
to be free
this is
a huge mistake i want to be free
no one will even want to come near you
you will be alone
alone
alone
i want to be free
you